so sieht die lage die lage ist entspannt
obwohl die lage ist eigentlich stressig
wiesen unterwegs wir machen jetzt gerade
jetzt geht's los
die arbeiten fürs album raus straße
sieht man nicht passiert nichts wann
kommt das album kommt am 15
und so sagt entspannt aber für dich ist
das ein komplett neuer schritt auf jeden
fall das ist jetzt komplett neu jetzt
keine parodie jetzt wird auf dem album
gearbeitet
und ja heißt aber nicht vom gangster zum
musiker sondern vom gangster zu
ingenieuren gingst du zumindest mal
richtig was ist jetzt kein haupt ding
ist das ingenieur werden ist das rapper
sein ist sind es die brüder
was ist für dich das nicht mehr kann man
alles man kann alles machen klar es ist
schwierig aber dieses album wollte ich
immer schon mal bringen und deswegen
mache ich sie einfach die leute machen
das album sehr gut geworden und es ist
halt schwierig jetzt nachdem parodien
dass die leute das erstmal so
realisieren was sie da machen und dann
noch das studium aber studium habe ich
jetzt passiert im urlaub zu bester
genommen damit ich schön alpen arbeiten
du bist also der titel sagt ja schon ein
wenig etwas über den lebensweg aus und
wenn du jetzt saß ich habe jetzt erst
mal studium unterbrochen urlaubssemester
genommen mache jetzt erst dieses ding
was ist sowohl nach welche richtung
schlägst du ein wo daran orientiert du
dich was ist das was dich
ja motiviert etwas zu tun wie meinst du
sitzt ja was du machst parodien wie seid
ihr auf den bau gehen gekommen jetzt
dann hast aber ein studium angefangen
was sind die motive was wenn du etwas
machst was bewegt dich dazu es zu tun
also studium war ganz klare
entscheidungen von mir weil mein vater
wollte auch das studieren aber ich
wollte auch selber meine brüder mark und
zu studieren
ein kleiner bruder ist auch inzwischen
schon genau aladin ist jetzt ist jetzt
bei seiner bachelor arbeit gerade erst
so gut die fertigkeit braucht noch mehr
ich schenke noch ein bisschen härter ran
wie was motiviert mich studium auf jeden
fall eine gute sache wenn du studierst
am ende hast einen sicheren job und dann
geht's dir gut halten dann muss nicht
irgendwie zu kämpfen ob du bist in china
und dann war es ein anderes leben musik
parodien haben wir angefangen spontan
das war ganz spontan irgendwie so ewer
machen comedy bisschen witzig haben wir
früher auch schon mal gemacht hat sich
mit ergeben haben weitergemacht und
schweißen und dieses album jetzt zwar
einfach meine entscheidung ich hatte
lust einfach das zu machen jetzt mit dem
status kann ich mir das erlauben
kennst du vorher nicht gemacht wenn du
nicht diesen status erreicht ist ein
album so im markt bringen so nie
aufgefallen dass das ging jetzt besser
oder leichter was hat's ja klar ich bin
jetzt etwas bekannter kennen die leute
und ich kann jetzt sowas bringen und ich
also ich kann gute musik jetzt auch
beweisen ich kann den leuten meine musik
zeigen damals wenn ich etwas auf youtube
problem aber vielleicht 300.000 klicks
gehabt man jetzt gehts bisschen besser
prüfen und wenn ich mir die texte so
anhöre das geht ja auch in eine andere
richtung also erstmal natürlich keine
parodie aber es ist auch sehr
ernsthaftes ist
eben nicht sag mal was jetzt vielleicht
gangster im titel nahelegen würde dass
du deine her kommt vielleicht preist und
ich waren kriegs- gangster- und sondern
es geht mehr in die richtung hey ich bin
ernsthaft und denkt mal drüber nach was
er macht so sieht ist das was die
gefehlt hat in der rap szene
ja das hat mir auf jeden fall gefehlt
weil die musik ist keine ahnung auf
jeden fall ist irgendwie jeder rap das
gleiche jeder wird über drogen und kilos
und bleibt was er da gemacht hat und das
hören sich keine kinder und es ist auf
jeden fall nicht schlimm es ist immer
noch musik
wenn jetzt jemand sage ich hab die logik
heißt das nicht dass die ganzen kinder
anfang zu drogen zu nehmen aber das ist
halt web das das gilt natürlich auch
dazu aber bei mir geht es jetzt halt ein
bisschen anders
ich sag jetzt auch nicht dass die blumen
pflücken
aber ich bin zum beispiel dass das nur
eine drogen nichts zu tun haben soll um
cool zu sein oder was auch immer
dass es andere wege gibt und also ich
habe auch nicht was mit drogen zu tun
gehabt trotzdem bin ich kein welche okay
was ist für dich denn was macht ein kohl
was macht ein kuhlmann muss man im kopf
haben erst mal wenn du irgendwann was im
kopf hat dann kann man schon mal
arbeiten dann kann man auf jeden fall
schon mal etwas erreichen etwas machen
man muss standhaft sein natürlich man
muss seinen mann stehen was immer auch
passiert
cool was heißt cool wenn du wenn du was
erreicht dass du deinen eltern zeigen
kann smart papademos geschafft habe und
diesen stolz drauf das ist cool
ok nun kommt also warum siehst warum
glaubst es bei anderen ebenen sind er
drogen cool und hassen ich weiß nicht
was warum ist das bei dir nie so
angekommen
warum hast du dem nicht nachgeliefert
drogen war bei mir sowieso immer ein no
go
also ich habe drogen genommen wurde so
erzogen keine ahnung meine brüder auch
nicht also keiner von uns nimmt
irgendwelche drogen oder hat irgendwie
irgendwelche drogen probiert also ich
hab noch nie mal eben so braucht oder so
kann man vielleicht nicht glauben aber
ist so drogen verabscheue ich richtig
auch im album wenig das oft dass das
nicht meine sache ist sich so mit drogen
habe ich nichts am hut gehabt
ab frühjahr zwar sachen gemacht aber
keine rolle
und wie kommt das also ist es ist dass
erziehung oder hasst dem freundeskreis
erfahrungen gemacht sagt haben eine
erziehung auf jeden fall nummer 1 also
mein vater hat mich streng erzogen
förderlich gerade erzogen meine brüder
immer darauf aufgepasst auch dass ich
sauber bleibe ich war immer mit dem
herzen
ich konnte nichts falsches machen und
freundeskreis auch ganze weise meine
freundeskreises mit denen ich früher
vielleicht gibt es eins zwei freunde
denen ich früher war die jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen weggekommen sind
aber 90 prozent aller meiner freunde
sind immer noch bei mir und diesen genau
wie ich und die bleiben so stand dachte
ich was ist das rezept bleiben
abzudriften
das rezept oder das heißt rezept man
muss halt mit den richtigen leuten
unterwegs sein man muss aufpassen mit
dem man unterwegs ist man soll denn es
gibt viele freunde klar aber man soll
halt drei vier leute mit denen man immer
ist und ich kann man den kleinen kids da
draußen sagen wenn euch jemand was
anbietet oder zu probieren
keine ahnung hat ihn das ding weg den
joint oder was auch immer das ist nicht
cool
also macht man guten freundes einen
guten freund macht aus der dir sowas
überhaupt nicht anbietet wenn er selber
nimmt er selber sagt er auf damit zum
beispiel ich habe einen guten freund ich
habe angefangen zu rauchen
das einzige was ich mache und ich rauche
leider noch nicht gut aber auf jeden
fall hatte ich schon freuen zum beispiel
und ich wollte nicht dass er braucht der
hat das mal gemacht und ich habe ihm das
sozusagen nicht erlaubt damit das nicht
gut
hat da nicht viel gebracht werden
angefangen zu rauchen aber halt so der
ein freund teil sowieso ein bruder alten
das sind freunde der auf eine nachricht
richtig halte mama da ist wenn du uns
brauchst und nicht nur aber muss man
sich aber scheinbar ja scheiße baue ich
habe scheiße gebaut klar womit der
gangster sind ja ich habe viel scheiße
gebaut natürlich ich habe scheiße gebaut
ja also
hier und da mal was mitgenommen und da
eingebrochen blut ja einige sagte ich
habe schon einige sachen nicht so aber
aber ich bin gut weggekommen weil es
nichts gebracht habt also du hast 10.000
euro gemacht irgendwo und weg nach einem
hat kommt das sagen das immer so das
kommt dies geht so wie es gekommen so
geht es auch schnell gekommen und
wehklagen gehst du hier raus mit zehn
freunden er ich habe zehn mark in hessen
150 sie hat gesagt das ist wirklich so
wie man lebt das schlägt auf allen
zurück wenn du gut lebt dann kommt dem
begegnet der gutes und wenn du
schlechtes tust dann begegnet ihr
einfach schlechtes wenn du das geld
nicht ehrlich verdient hast wird es dir
auch zwischen den fingern verrichtet
richtig alles aus seinen erfahrungen das
ist auf jeden fall meine erfahrung alles
was man mit dreckigen geld macht ist
egal was du kaufst dir irgendwas kaputt
oder was auch immer genau so gesagt
beim hingreifen recht das ist klar dass
es kommt von gott wir sind alle
gläubiger also ich bin sehr gläubig dass
das kommt das merkt man auf jeden fall
dass da irgendwas was passiert immer
egal was dann denkst du dir das fällt
ihr nicht sofort ein aber dann im
nachhinein denke ich hab das und das
gemacht jetzt dass das am ende habe ich
- okay das heißt auch teile these ist
ehrlichkeit und aufrichtigkeit ist ein
minusgeschäft richtig du musst immer
ehrlich bleiben immer sauber bleiben
konz keiner kann von anderen pro tag
nehmen das ist nicht gut und das ist
jetzt auch deine botschaft das ist meine
botschaft genau das ist meine botschaft
aber ich berichte natürlich auch was ich
erlebt habe und was man nicht machen
sollte was man macht merkt
warum glaubst das ansonsten bei capcom
zu ärgern es gibt ja im moment zwei
richtungen entweder knallharte oder ist
es mehr ein bisschen gruselig und das
ist knallhart aber dass jemand so
ehrlich rappt und sagt ich will aber
über was gutes werten gibt gibt's das
daher kommen bei mir auch von natürlich
er ist immer noch red ja also ich wie
gesagt mein album ist immer noch rap
aber ich sag jetzt nicht erich dicke
kinos oder ich kokain durch die nase
ziehen oder sonst was nicht wahr
keine ahnung das hat sich leider von
abgeguckt und alle anderen halt auch die
briten wollten mehr geld muss und das
sagen damit sich erfolgreich werde
okay ich hab alles gemacht was sagen in
deiner kumpels dass du jetzt ernsthaft
selbst seine brüder die anderen von hp
wollen sicherlich freuen sich endlich
dass das dann kommt weil meine musik
kann leute immer schon gehört hat er
damals immer so musik gemacht haben
gemäss ich irgendwas aufgenommen wurde
immer schon gefeiert die cdu zusammen
zum beispiel freuen sich alle
unterstützt mich auch überall wo es geht
das gefühl dass das machen zu können es
ist eine super gefühl auf jeden fall
aber man hat natürlich auch ein bisschen
angst wie kommt es an wird sowas auftakt
mal ab mal gucken muss natürlich nicht
direkt gold gehen ist das ein traum
gewesen ja jetzt nicht so ein traum also
ein traum von mir sind aber ja klar aber
schon immer schon bock drauf gehabt ich
habe bock drauf gemacht um drauf gehabt
und deswegen mache ich das bin jungen
habt seid ich kann es mir erlauben
gut dann was ist denn dein traum was
wäre ein traum was ist die erfüllung
mein traum ist später ins paradies zu
kommen
70 jungfrauen
also mein traum hier in der welt ist auf
jeden fall gesund bleiben das ist mein
zimmer schönen gesundheit kann man nicht
kaufen egal wie geld du hast du krank
bist hast du lys davon
die einen arm fehlt dann kannst du auch
kränken dass ich ganz nicht mehr boxen
wie zum beispiel früher oder wenn du
kein bein mehr als du kannst kein
fußball mehr spielen
wie gesagt gesund bleiben stehen an
erster stelle
und natürlich soll das mich später gut
gehen meiner familie also schon wieder
aus so dass jetzt will ich mal dass die
typische bewerbungsgespräch frage
stellen
du siehst du dich in sofia bist du etwa
oder bist du tierisch erfolgreich mit
den hbw bruders web parodien oder bist
du ingenieur soll ich mal ganz ehrlich
sagen
am liebsten keine ahnung echt ehrlich
ich weiß nicht mal gucken also wie
gesagt studium bin ich noch nicht so
weit aber ist das werde ich auf jeden
fall durchziehen was kommt was wäre also
wenn ich fertig bin mein studium
da muss man ja nicht sofort arbeiten
gerne dann guckt man halt so macht wie
die lage ist
nur wie ist die lage wie ist die lage
schau mal wie die lage ist weiß ich
nicht
wenn ich in dieser vielleicht arbeite
ich irgendwo nach firma für ein wandel
keine ahnung vielleicht bin ich fertig
auf 1 mit 80.000 in der woche oder
vielleicht werde ich zu gerne eingeladen
einer comedy show auf eis nicht oder
alles zusammen
wenn eltern nichts dazu die dann macht
die
die wissen nicht einschätzen
sie wissen jetzt dass die haben doch
sehr zum mitbekommen das wäre in youtube
oder welche faxen machen dass uns die
leute kennen und die freuen sich darüber
natürlich nicht alle stolz auf uns auf
jeden fall und die listen leid dass wir
sauber sind und das was man uns
vertrauen kann und die verfolgen uns
auch eigentlich ja auch zu meckern
alltägliches gesagt und ich solche wird
das nicht gut auf mein vater immer
direkt mit dem glauben heraus dass nicht
gut das macht mich aber ja wir machen
die sind jung die sind da machen und er
es auf jeden fall stolz auf uns gutes
gefühl gutes gefühl
bist du glaubst du hast du so das gefühl
dass du das genau das richtige ist mag
richtige macht oder fehlt irgendwas
wurde sarah das wäre doch schön oder
bist du wirklich sehr ich bin zufrieden
marienfeier also bei mir läuft alles gut
gibt eigentlich nichts was gerade so
schlecht ist alles läuft alles läuft er
ist auch ein bisschen stress zwei videos
auch dann würde ich sagen ich drücke ja
wahnsinnig die daumen dass das wort und
du in jeglicher hinsicht eine steile
karriere hinlegt und wir werden weiter
dorf ich danke dir viel erfolg mit
klicks sulanke abonniert den kanal bitte
alle kamen alle kanäle abonnieren und
kein interview bei klicks und verpassten
absolut genau ich danke dir danke dir